you told a story about seeing some dead
bodies the other day
we should have saved it for this one but
maybe that would have made more sense
well maybe we cut it into this episode
or maybe we just make it as confusing as
the first season of this of the show the
usual technique and process yeah just
finding it finding it as we go but i
think it's fun that the audience is
finding it as we find it so it's a
shared experience what do you mean
well i mean you know they're seeing the
creative process in action where it's
like hey this doesn't work right but
we're going to air it anyway because we
want you to be
a part of the process uh listener mm-hmm
okay so are you saying you're going to
get feedback from people on this thing
no and they're going to make it this is
an outgoing communication got it but i
think it's going to be fun for people to
to kind of see how how bad things can
get
well let me ask you a question rob okay
since we're talking about this how do
you feel the podcast is going so far i
think it's pretty good
i think if our general rule is like we
always kind of approach the show this
way which is like if we're laughing then
at least it's fun for us
and i think that alone is a good enough
reason to do it and what if we're not
laughing like right now
well sometimes not could also be
interesting yeah life's not always about
laughter there's lots of you know i mean
you know like what's your take on god
you know that guy well we addressed that
in the show we addressed that we did
well and it's always sunny in
philadelphia oh right yeah
i think you know i i for a long time i
felt this pressure and i think it's
understandable to be funny all the time
when doing like interviews and podcasts
and you know red carpet events and
things like that and um
i found that it was taking me to a
really dark place because i was
resilient
wait you were getting dark to a dark
place can you believe that can you
believe that
yeah guys you know what's funny what
dead bodies what
[Music]
now in this episode we found a dead body
and we started with
with a crack about tom brady now at the
time it was 2005
correct and uh i believe we had just
watched him uh i just watched him beat
the eagles and that would have made it
three super bowls for tom brady in
all right about 2005 and i think we were
making some sort of joke about how we
were going to hurt him
yes and of course then d rightfully so
suggests that there's no way we could
beat up tom brady tom brady would beat
the living crap out of all of us
especially me and then either way tom
brady went on to win four more three
more super bowls after that and play in
five
maybe six
and he's played in about 10 afc
champions i mean the last super bowl
there was he won yeah rob had dinner
with tom brady the other night yeah
that's where you've gotten to in life
and did you really
you invited me a kid from new england
and uh i didn't i i declined i didn't
feel like going thank you what he didn't
want to go man
yeah my wife did a commercial with tom
brady in the early 2000s i don't
remember what was for some sort of
credit card or something like that you
can i think you can find it online
somewhere i think we looked it up on
youtube once because i wanted to see
that
glenn did you do i did a ton of
commercials did you do commercials i
tried you know i have a funny little
story about when i first graduated from
college and i was meeting with like
agents and things like that i met with a
commercial agent is that what they're
called yeah
abram's artist was the was the joint in
new york i remember yeah there was one
other one cunningham
eminem that's that's the eminem that's
what i was with that's who i was with
too yeah okay i forgot the name good
good memory so i went shiffman ekman
morrison and mark's marx
no that's s-e-m-m
okay and i'm an m
i think that's i think that's the one
that i was with anyway i went to meet
with uh somebody there who was like one
of the main guys there or whatever i'm
like waiting for a long time they've got
me sat at like a coffee table area or
whatever guy finally shows up he comes
in he sits down across from me
and he just looks at me you know just
looks at me and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is going on i'm like hi hi nice to meet
you he's like yeah mm-hmm
just like i know just looks like you
know this i don't know i know of course
i don't i don't know yeah either you do
you do you do it i don't maybe you'll
get it when you get it you'll remember
it i don't know i think you'll remember
it when i say it yeah so he's just
staring at me looking at me and i'm like
this is [ __ ] so weird like he's
taking like a full i mean you know like
the longest 15 seconds of my life you
know he finally he goes
bhb
keep in mind i'm like this kid just
straight out of call i wasn't really a
kid like 24. uh i felt like a kid
and i'm like oh i'm i'm sorry i'm what
do you what do you mean he's like
bhb
and i was like
i'm so sorry i don't i'm i'm new to this
but i don't know what you're saying blow
him boy
somebody chimes in from another office
blow him by behind the glass wall
well filming
it's still the late 90s he could get
away with it
um no that's not what bh that's not what
bhb stands for but i mean this guy he
was so [ __ ] douchey it was like he
was he just he loved like that i didn't
know what he was talking about he loved
the power or it was the weirdest [ __ ]
thing and i was like i'm so sorry i
don't know the terms i don't know what
that is i don't know what you're saying
to me i'm so sorry you know i'm just i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry i'm a child
he was like
big head's book
oh my god never heard this story so he
was both i wouldn't remember that i
would remember that he was looking at me
he was looking at my head and he was
going you're going to book stuff because
you've got a big head and big head's
book
and you know what he was wrong well i
don't know about that i mean john
travolta has got the biggest head that
has ever been put on do you know so does
danny devito
well yeah that's true yeah
that's a that's a bowling ball it's an
it's an extra large bowling ball it's
not sitting atop his shoulders
i didn't book any commercials though to
answer your question i didn't book a
single [ __ ] well because you didn't
blow them like let's be honest that's
really what it was that's what bhb
really stopped
he can't get you the commercials though
he's just getting you in the door then
you got to do that you got to get in
that door and then start blowing but i
also by the way i also probably went to
10 commercial auditions total before i
just went you know what i don't care how
much money it is i'm not doing this
anymore and i i just i've just stopped
going because i was like i'll live off
400 a week doing off-broadway plays this
is so [ __ ] humiliating yeah i hate
and this by the way no offense to people
who do commercials i get it you make a
lot of money it's a great way to make a
living and certainly if you've got a
family of feet it makes a lot of sense
personally i just i did not like it i
didn't like it i didn't like how it made
me feel i didn't like the auditions i
was like this is a [ __ ] coming out of
juilliard where you're like working on
scene and character and they're like all
right so here
the soup's really hot and you got to
tell your buddy give him that like oh my
god it's hot look but like a whole guy
like really like a big you know and then
the hot chick walks by and you you're
like but that's hot too and then you're
like you know someone yells doritos and
then you know and then your eyes pop out
yeah and then maybe say something funny
but don't yeah and then uh yeah yeah and
then there's only four or 500 other guys
that are looking for the same part and i
had the opposite experience i booked the
first commercial audition i ever went in
on wow yeah wow it was for foot locker
you were you did a lot of wait is hey
can we find can can can the listener
find uh your foot locker commercial on
youtube it's not out there my cascade
ones out there what was the one where
you were on the stairs you were passing
somebody on some stairs maybe you're
talking about babies oh that's thomas
bagels that's out there yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they voice over somebody else's
no no that was um what they put somebody
else's voice
when you're on a date
yeah where
i'm on a date and the girl throws water
in my face and then it cuts to like a
box of excedrin and they say like uh i
didn't know she was your sister so it's
implied that i
was staring at her sister or something
and it was about like some tabs that
dissolve quickly you don't need water
like that was a joke
i did a like a two hour session with the
with the producers trying to get me to
say i didn't know she was your sister
in the way that they wanted
and i was like they probably were just
hearing this voice and being like i
didn't know that voice was on that face
this is what are we gonna do here love
the
was like a british accent
if i may uh charlie
you know and look you're still a very
handsome man but you were
strikingly handsome as a young man wow
truly i don't understand why
you cover it up with the beard all the
time because i whenever you shave i'm
always like look at that [ __ ] guy
what happened with the jawline look at
it very handsome here's what happened
with the beard we we were like oh would
be funny for the character to do the to
have the beard sonny he's
scraggly and he's you know sloppy he's
not taking care of himself he doesn't
care about like a nice shape
and then
we never stopped doing the show yeah so
then i would be between gigs and they
were like well
you might as well just keep the beard
because then it's gonna like we're gonna
run back into sunny and then i just and
then it was like well now if you take
the beard off it's gonna frighten people
and disappoint them so i just kept the
beard
but that's nice to say glenn i did not
feel strikingly handsome growing up
you've got a very you've got a very
handsome very symmetrical face well
thank you thank you and i enjoy looking
at it on a daily basis and you know what
you also look good with a mustache women
did not agree with you when i was i
i think that i find that hard to believe
i didn't just i think maybe you weren't
picking up on it we were young men and
they would flock to the two of you and
they'd be like there's that one he
doesn't seem neurotypical and then they
would just go
away
well maybe the fact that you're you are
not neurotypical was just neurotypical
we don't know but like the things like
you know adhd or whatever are going to
like
but maybe you weren't picking up on the
social cues
once where i went like nine days with
her and she's like are you gonna kiss me
i'm like okay so this is like so you
want so this is something you want okay
you want my lips to all right okay yeah
i was not i was always the same way
charlie i i could i'm so
so so not like dennis in that regard i i
needed a big as you said flashing green
go sign before i would ever make a move
but mostly because i was just so
terrified of rejection
terrified of ever having a moment in my
life where i went to kiss a girl and she
was like new nope
charlie tells a great story of that
actually i did that once and that's kind
of that really scarred you
yeah
yeah well you know there was a girl that
liked her and we had a flirtatious
relationship and you know i think it was
probably your early 20s like 21 22
you've heard the story about of course
of course uh and horn i think i asked
hornsby i was like what's what's the
deal you know do you think she likes me
and hornsby's like just go just
just try
uh and then there was like a moment a
little charged moment where i thought
okay maybe this isn't and then i tried
to kiss her and her face
scrunched up like she just sucked like
900 lemons and i
i mean
steph stands that is that's why that's
the word that's got to be the worst
feeling she was very nice about it she's
like it's not you i do i'm there's this
guy that i'm with i'm like but i'm like
no it's it's it's me and i'm dead i'm so
sorry
did you apologize did you actually i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry for putting you
sorry no no no it's i'm so i misread the
room i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm i'll
be fine i'll be fine yeah um glenn you
said there's a noose around here
somewhere right yeah no but uh that was
fun that was that was the only one time
but you know rob uh you you were the
kind of person who would get rejected
and you'd just be like well i guess on
to the next like you you would you were
you were playing the numbers game
weren't you yeah but the rejection was
coming so often and it's such high
volume that it kind of like getting in
cold water yeah but i think that again
if we're gonna get back into uh the
psychology that we've set up earlier in
previous episodes i think it has
something to do with hitting puberty
late so you've got you gotta just try
you know like you're 17 16 17 and all
like the met like the boys who are
becoming men are the ones that are
attractive to the women not the five
foot two
obnoxious one right so i was trying just
just
just doing my best to you know
but i mean this this was still the case
well into your 20s yeah because i took
that with me which was like i didn't
take it even though i should have taken
it personally because it is quite
personal to try to attract a woman in
her to reject you right but i would take
the rejection and then i would just i
would say okay thank you very much and
then i'd move on to the next rejection i
think that's good listen
on some level i think that's very very
healthy i think it's good to
acclimate yourself to look go after what
you want and acclimate yourself to
failure so that it doesn't completely
destroy you and you still continue to
pursue whatever it is that you're going
through yeah you're like a tick like the
tick doesn't mind if someone picks you
know flicks it across the room and picks
it out of the hair it goes and finds
other hair you know and like you're like
a tick rob it also oh i've excited i say
i accepted that a long time ago i've
i've attached myself to you guys
yeah i did it to megan too i mean i did
it to my wife
you guys are aware of it hey guys shut
up he's a human parasite hey guys shut
the hell up um today as podcast is
brought to you by
air
um 95 percent of air breathers survive
breathe air
get air in your mouth
this episode that we just watched
so much of our transition music
i feel like dennis you're finding dennis
a little bit in this the dynamic between
the two you you're funny
max really finding his sexuality i think
we you see this the seeds being planted
that we knew we were going to use
later down the road with matt coming out
that was very clear
that sarcasm doesn't play there were a
lot of firsts in this episode we've
found some new transition music as you
said this is the first time where like
we actually
wrote funny stuff for dee like pretty
much from start to finish where she
wasn't a wet blanket she had a very
funny
objective which is to
try and you know overcome her fear of
old people to try and have a
relationship with her grandfather but
she's so disgusted by old people that
she can't move past it and it was just
really fun to watch caitlyn finally get
to do something really really funny it's
kind of like a defensive
mode for her and i think we've we really
kind of hit a stride with her when we
made her go pure offensive oh totally
yeah and we made her just as despicable
as we are because you're right the
comedy came from a much more of a
reactive place than an active place also
the first time it feels like we have one
of those scenes that we then went to the
well and continue to go to the well
because it's so fun of the two
characters sitting across from some
authority figure right yeah and trying
to do something ridiculous right i mean
you're talking about the museum curator
trying to sell the nazi uniform yes
right profit
and not picking up on the queues and
just sort of like barreling through it
and yeah yeah and i think i'll bet you
you could go through our editing room
and find uh we always we would always
shoot and we i think we still do it from
time to time is shoot headers to those
scenes because we're like already in the
chairs generally and the person is
coming into their sorry i'm late
and so we usually would shoot a scene we
definitely scripted and we shoot a scene
but basically talking about what we were
going to do the characters were like
okay here's what we're going to do and
here's why we're going to do it and then
we didn't have enough experience to
realize like well why don't we just do
it instead of talk about what we're
going to do and yet we kept writing it
and kept shooting it so i'll bet you
there's like hundreds of those scenes
that you've never seen headers
that are where the characters are
explaining what they're about they're
just riveting yeah and we would do it at
the end of a scene too she's like now
let's go to so-and-so's or something
like that yeah yeah but we i think at
least we had the presence of mind to cut
that stuff in the editing room i mean
it's not so bad to shoot it have it in
case for some reason you get in the
editing room and you realize sure you
know this is actually a little confusing
i can't i don't know why sometimes you
don't hey guys i caught another band
sticker in that bar scene
i think it's a band avenge seven fold
did you have you guys been seeing look
at that yeah
we did crack the case of those thrice
stickers we did we remembered that there
was a a person who worked in that herald
examiner building that was the old
newspaper paper factory that the bar set
was in
[Music]
who was sticking those stickers off yeah
baxter backs backs you son of a [ __ ]
you had no right to do that you had no
right to push your agenda on our
audience your thrice and backs agenda
all over our show now i will say that
there is a system of checks and balance
that that balances that is in place for
that like say the art department who
might be right looking to see what's
being did we have an article i don't
know
i bet there was a deal that was pretty
bare bones yeah
that was cut yeah money was changing me
get these stickers in here and
bathroom baxter cut some deals under our
nose and got his stickers up backside
that's a dirty bird that's a real
downtown l.a mentality yeah yeah
he came in with a few things he was like
can i kiss the lead actress they're like
no
uh that's right well you sent me the
extras to my trailer my trailer no can i
put the stickers up yeah you know that's
probably what happened there you go and
also like that's right this is going to
be a little bit sadder than the other
requests but can i just hang out with
you guys i remember him
no he did that's what i'm saying
avenged sevenfold has a song on spotify
that has been listened to
319 million times so guys we
started
yes
that's what i'm talking about
it's a [ __ ] ac dc i like it yeah
that's some ac dc [ __ ] isn't it
i can get down with this
[Music]
oh
how about some lyrics it just sort of
goes on and on like that for 15 [ __ ]
minutes 300 million 300 million people
are like enjoy the never ending intro to
a song um no that sounded great guys
avenged sevenfold pretty good my
apologies you're better at what you do
than we are you guys are clearly very
good at what you're doing and again just
like with thrice i'm gonna hit the gym
i'm gonna put on your album and you've
got one song to hook me because i don't
have a lot of patience yeah
get one song guys
here's genuine question about that first
season which i do not recall rob where
were you living when we shot that very
first season we had apartments right
next to each other was that season one
yeah of season one yeah rob had an
apartment on coldwater canyon with chris
backus yes but after that i lived with
charlie then yeah you lived in my house
for a little bit for a little while and
then you gotta kick the [ __ ] out of
there and then because you guys were
getting married because you were gonna
get married and you were like
you don't need a roommate and then you
were and then you were living in shiloh
strong's guest house
for the first part of it yes you were
and when we shut the fx pilot and all
that you were but by the end because i
actually specifically remember writing
to bring it back to this episode
us working on this episode together and
going through stuff
in what became your apartment which was
literally right next to my apartment in
west hollywood on
crescent heights my memory of that is
that you guys were there when we did the
pilot but you guys were there when we
did the first season huh yeah so the
pilot i was definitely in in the garage
you were in the garage i think for quite
a bit of that and then we did the first
season shiloh strong i wonder how that
guy's doing he's going to text with him
once in a while yeah i i i talk i've
talked to him a couple times but i
haven't seen him as much brother of or
strong brother of right or strong yeah
boy meets world world yeah and many
other things yeah writer strong who i
always felt like kind of looked like you
charlie similar look it's kind of
similar looks like i feel like you and
writer strong could definitely play
brothers cool well i'll pretend i know
who that that is oh okay
no i know it is but i need pictures i
need at least acknowledge what a [ __ ]
cool name that is it's a cool name is
this bright or strong do you remember
what their dad's name was yes king
arthur strong no it wasn't i swear to
god wasn't it
am i making that up
no i swear to god no i swear to god
google it look it up megan i swear to
god shiloh and oh that dude yeah i know
yeah they look at that guy come on make
it i can't remember names i face is no
problem king arthur strong yeah what did
i say a firefighter he's a firefighter i
remember these things these guys are
back i figured he would have worked at
like uh you know like one of those
one of those places where you can
pretend to be a knight and a king and uh
oh yeah medieval times medieval times
that's what it is and i remember that
shiloh was very handy uh yeah like he he
was all he was a volunteer firefighter
he was a volunteer fighter he was also
doing a bunch of [ __ ] in his house all
the time i mean the guy he was an actor
and a good one
uh but he was he also had like a lot of
other [ __ ] that he was into which is
also so healthy because i never had any
of that yeah you know play a little
basketball on the side but not very good
at it always twisting my ankle and
whatnot
uh
[Music]
yeah
yeah well that's how's your ankle now
well i don't i don't play basketball
anymore but it's fine it's fine yeah
it's fine it healed but uh it scarred me
for a while i was not aggressive scared
scared to take it to the hole i was
taking scared right i was scared to
bring it all the way to the hospital we
would play bad that was like we did play
basketball
basis you did roll your ankle one time
were you there oh yeah for that one that
was the big one that destroys a bad one
then you guys got into racquetball for a
little bit we sure did well because you
could play it at the y yeah we were
because we were editing well we were
editing anger issues these things my i
had much more anger issues than you did
buddy you were breaking transferred you
were smashing racquetball rackets left
and right you were really so angry it
was hard to watch
you lost that i kind of liked it yeah i
lost it i kind of liked it what do you
attribute that to wild success and money
wait a minute wait a minute what are you
talking growing up
you know the bruce springsteen it's not
all about you and you can let stuff go a
little bit i think so that's great i
think so thanks but how many golf clubs
have you smashed in the last year go no
amen you've not been tossing clubs i'm
super proud of you okay in the last two
years in the last two years i've bro
i've broken one or two clubs but name me
a golfer who hasn't
made me a golfer who hasn't i've only
smashed one phone and i smashed one one
laptop but that's cause the laptop was
was pooping out on me already and i
punched it and the screen
shattered and it was kind of awesome oh
that's cool i wish i could i mean i pun
i punched it as hard as i could and it
like did exactly what you wanted
that's [ __ ] awesome dude you really
got made contact with it yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's exactly what it wanted it
splintered the screen yes the screen
splintered like a windshield
[Laughter]
what are you doing rob
oh
jesus i cannot i i immediately shamed
myself
right didn't i call you meg i was like i
have to tell people i went to caitlyn i
was like caitlyn i'm a child i can't
believe i just did this i'm 43 years old
i punched a computer
and it was awesome
sticking with this bit what are you
doing over there
what am i doing rob
you're doing uh space odyssey 2001 a
space odyssey that's right
i don't remember that that scene as he's
shutting down he's singing daisy daisy
and he's getting it's getting slower and
slower yeah delete the files guys oh you
can't delete that one that's the
greatest movie everyone want to that's
great i think we should have a whole
separate podcast maybe as a bonus
episode
of stories that i know that you guys
know that you told each other well you
remember them all though i don't know
why i do just name it
what just happened today no no no i've
never heard that story
well that's the thing you don't know
what you don't remember no he's saying
stories that don't remember that he does
yeah that he he told you you know what
story was this well he's talking oh my
god
i don't recall this php what did this
out what's bhb you have said
i've never heard this i think on every
it's fascinating to say that you've
never heard and you you're saying that
with such confidence you've never heard
that story before when also i mean 30
seconds ago and once every podcast you
make it very clear that you delete files
right yeah
no i've never said that
[Music]
you know what i really love in that
episode guys
uh the moment where kaitlyn where sweet
d
throws up through her fingers oh that's
a very specific thing that anyone who's
ever gotten a little too drunk or been a
little too sick knows that thing of
where you're like running to try to get
to the [ __ ] toilet all the time you
don't quite get there so it just comes
right through your fingers oh
it's a funny thing when we ever whenever
we do a scene like that you got to put a
little cream and mushroom soup in your
mouth and it's cold and it actually
really does make you feel like you're
going to throw up it makes you feel like
you have a mouth full of throttle well
it depends on the kind of food you're
used to eating if you're used to eating
a diet like i eat it actually tastes
pretty good
is that two or three vomit scenes in
this first
is there another one because i think we
maybe even shot another one and we were
like oh there's this guy guys what are
we doing yeah what are we doing we're
the vomit show yeah or the poopy peepee
and vomit show oh yeah but you know what
it's how certain people are going to
label us no matter what we do when
people talk about life being like a
simulation you know it's all one big
computer simulation and it's not uh yeah
explain to me diarrhea
like like why like that part of the
simulation yeah why does someone want to
simulate that what are they trying to
swear they want to take you down to pay
what are they yeah what are they trying
to do
needs to take you down a peg like so i
was simulating a clan the other day and
then i thought i'd i'd have them run so
i gave them those stomach cramps and
you're like right in the bathroom is
that the computer programmer talking or
is that the computer and whoever's
enjoying the simulation
oh it's the oh it's the overlord who's
actually yeah
yeah so i get glenn diary oh you get
glenn diary well i gave him a job yeah
well yeah it's not just one person
giving everyone diarrhea come on no way
not possible not possible it's the
stupidest thing i got a question for you
guys
i thought it was just sort of ending why
and this is for anyone really but like
why do people want to see
the dead bodies of their loved ones
after they die i i look i can't
understand that closure closure you
can't close with you like i need to see
the person that i loved
dead and lifeless in order to close that
chapter i understand both i understand
both sides of that
okay
i i i find the whole thing so [ __ ]
morbid well also yeah because death is
involved yeah and so no that's not
no i i just that is the definition
before that would be it right i know i
know yeah what are we going to say
you know somebody dies suddenly and yes
your
brain can accept the fact that like that
is life and death and
you need to you need that final image of
the dead body burned into your brain so
that that's the thing you remember yes
even though you that makes sense you can
recognize
you could well that's what i mean it's
not it's not an intellectual pursuit
it's an emotional one you uh i mean okay
so it's been a couple days your friend
has died and you're still so emotional
that you're like i want the last image
of my friend or my loved one to be
their lifeless [ __ ] corpse well glenn
what turn up like a like what if you
didn't see them what if you didn't see
them what if the moment where they've
seen them before that's why you're at
the funeral
you've seen them many times they're your
friend your loved one yes okay uh glenn
we can cut this but
let's say your
kid is missing
okay your child is missing yes and then
you find out that your child is dead
yeah
do not want to see the body absolutely
not no [ __ ] way not even not in a
million years
i would say that that takes a lot of
discipline i understand discipline why
do i want to see my kid's dead [ __ ]
body well again it seems horrible to me
yes it is i don't want to see that i
don't want to see that maybe i think it
the the psychology sometimes is to know
that it's real uh-huh you know to be
like like
i can't it's this is so such a shocking
chill
look at it i'll jill look at it you put
her through it
she's like that's good just got this got
this got that got that got that cut that
contact cut
seriously dude cut that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah we'll be out before you start
talking about it yeah let's do that
we've done it
we did it
love you guys bye
[Applause]